okay let's go let's go
first I'd like to say that this is a
strange talk if I kind of thought that I
didn't know where to put it in what in
what event good feed and since I know
the organization of this conference that
I shall submit it here because it's a it
is a talk that it's designed for both
for a very some narrow audience because
it's not only about complexity in
distributed applications that run in
parallel it's also about applications
that are developed by several people who
here's had to manage a group of five
developers six developers okay you've
probably realized that managing six
people is way more difficult than
managing 6 servers ok and this um so
this talk is about these kind of things
I mean what happens when you have to
manage a system that it's both
distributed because it runs tributed and
because it's made by different people
and honestly I expected the smaller
audience I usually give talks in in
conferences with almost empty rooms
because I like to talk about weird
things this is my Twitter I don't spam
so not too much my PhDs on aerospace
engineering yes I did a PhD on a word
stuff probably know about more about
theory of turbulence that I know about
computing and now I work at a company
that's also sponsors this this event and
I have kind of shirt position with the
Carlos Tucker University I usually say
that I use Python because if before it
was cool it doesn't have I mean it's not
nothing special anything special but I
usually say that I used numeric when I
go to conferences very few people has
ever used in America and also used
gnuplot which is not a particularly good
thing and I organized the first pilot in
Spain was held last year in Madrid
come to me we're hiring
and all the material of this talk is in
this github repo including this article
which is kind of the point I don't write
books but I like to write articles and I
think that are relevant and there are no
more slides which is the kind of the
point we'll see that during the whole
talk I will try to make a point about
how you must deal with complexity by
communicating first things let's let me
introduce a small background about me
again I have a training as I've received
the training as a scientist I'm not a
computer scientist and during my PhD I
had to develop two kind of applications
once there are short programs that were
intended to eat some data process it
somehow and then generate a result there
were most of programs but I also had to
implement very large simulation codes
that run in very large supercomputers
I'm talking about millions of course
literally okay and the curious thing
with that both programs both kind of
programs no matter if they used a server
for a couple of hours or they use the
supercomputer for two years in both
cases the had performance issues so I
had to take care of performance because
I mean if when you do a PhD you cannot
run out of time you cannot spend ten
years in your PhD or basically or run
your life
in both cases are hard performance
issues and in this in the case of large
programs and our programs that literally
spent a hundred hundreds of millions of
CPU time in both cases those coats were
done by a single person and in a panic
mode constant panic mode okay it's
another nice place to be you developed
for one year and conflict panic mode so
you get older faster that's basically
what happens to you but when I finish my
PhD I was approached by a company and
they told me ok we think that you know
about computing
at least in a theoretical level we you
know about high performance computing
and they told me we have several tools
that may suffer from performance issues
in the future serious performance issues
in the future so we found an agreement
which is that I had two years to look
what was going on to understand what was
the problem to find the solution and to
implement it in Python really Python was
another requirement but I thought that
Python could do a great job at that I
will expand also my argument on that so
this is this at the point I mean at two
years there's a nice place to be had two
years for researching and again this
talk is about one one topic that it's
not very much discussed which is
application architecture and it is a
domain that's strange
because usually when you say okay I have
this very large application I want you
that you're an application architect
that's what it says in your business
card you're an application architect get
a lot of money by architecting
applications whatever that means
so what do you do and usually when you
ask an application architect they they
they always have the same answer which
is they tell you to repeat the same path
that they took so this is a kind of path
to success I've been successful you
repeat that and you will be successful
too and as I'm a scientist this triggers
me immediately because if you repeat
something you have no warranty that it
will be successful again otherwise if
you repeat a receipt for failure you can
be almost sure that you will fail again
okay so the problem was that I could not
understand what what were the company's
problems I couldn't understand what they
were doing so I decided to get my hands
dirty and kind of do everything from
scratch ok so again this is the
framework big applications years of
development tens of people are
applications that run maybe the design
the current design lasts four
case and they do such things as
assessing the whole risk of a complete
Bank so we're now talking about this
kind of script that you run for a month
so those things in which you have to
take some time to learn about the
architecture and doing it well
okay so how was the big way of solving
that for 50 years have you ever heard of
the entire architecture or the layer
architecture three layer collector which
is that you have a layer of data a layer
of business and a layer of presentation
and that's it this is dead completely I
mean if you go with that story to anyone
they will tell you I mean they will
basically fire you because that's
something that people did twenty years
ago now no one does that now you do big
applications and as a theory of why that
thing died most people think that that
it died because of performance issues
because you have a single pipeline and
you want to internet scale then you need
distributed stuff well that that's not a
problem of architecture what I think
that it killed that simple architecture
was complexity now you don't have a
single database you may have three
different databases maybe I have a
database right at the front end just for
caching maybe you have twenty-five
models for business maybe you have three
day for three different kind of clients
you have web clients we have mobile
clients they need different things or
you offer different things so this kind
of blew up because of complexity not
because of performance issues
performance also play the role but I
think that it wasn't the the thing that
killed it all so now we have a reality
is that things are distributed we have
lots of components and this is how
applications are done now we have a
series of components and we integrate
them for instance if you want to support
full-text search in your applications
what do you do what did you do ten years
ago you integrated full-text search
engine in your database the scene or
whatever now people don't even remember
what Lucy needs they just push the data
to elastics
and you have full-text search you want
to visualize you don't create your
visualization layer probably your
customer says okay I already have a
tableau license just use my tableau who
knows what the blue is so they're
telling you that just integrate this
component to me or to your tool because
I'm already paying that and there are
several tools I mean I've just set a
couple of examples so again this is
about integrating tools it's about and
of course if you if you integrate your
you make your application from
individual components that scale you
kind of wish that your application will
scale it is usually true but it's
wishful thinking so this has a byproduct
so you have all the things scatter
around and you have to glue it some glue
them somehow and I knew and I've been
told many times that python is a great
glue language the problem is that it's
no longer
you no longer need glue for gluing
different libraries you need glue for
gluing components and when I start
asking about that I got three kind of
answers was use a message queue or LA or
a broker like Kafka or mr. Sekulow 0 mq
or rabbitmq I mean they're a handful of
them just use a kind of streaming
library okay or so basically the word
two answers so the message queue or
string library but the problem when when
you want of someone tells you to use a
third party tool is that you must know
what you're about to do because you bet
on a third party tool that is basically
yet another component if that fits your
if you don't know enough about your
problem and you choose a tool and it
happens one year after you begin coding
the bets not right enough you're screwed
ok so that was my problem I didn't know
enough about my problem to choose a glue
so I did my own it's called the project
the whole private-school palm and my
glue is called pill py LM if you look at
the
the document you will find the link
there and it's it's something that was
designed to scratch our own itch and
it's been successful so at one of the
conclusions I will get it at the end I
mean building our own streaming library
was possible and it was successful okay
so again you have components scattered
all around a glue that glues all the
components together but that has an
important by-product it means that
there's no such thing as a business
layer it's scattered all around again
where's your business where's your
computational logic what's your two plus
two equal four it's all around and that
means that the the development has to be
distributed to because there's no such
thing as a huge library with all your
logic doesn't make sense anymore and
about that there's an important adage of
three years of theory who knows about
Conway's law no one else Conway law
Conway's law something that it's told to
you when you start developing in large
teams there's a short way of explaining
Conway law is that if you have five
people there will be four modules
because one has to lead okay
by the way this is not mine this is this
raises by is by the late Peter Hinton's
which gave great talks about this kind
of things and situated distance it means
that what Conway losses you cannot
decouple the social structure that you
use for coding the people from the
product they they make which is the code
and usually it was used as a sign of
warning is that if you don't improve the
communication between the developers you
will have a decoupled software okay what
we've realized after two years is that
you have to embrace that one model per
developer that's fine that has one
caveat which is that you have to be very
good at packaging and you need a kind of
a bookkeeper
who knows which model does what so you
don't throw away coke but it has a very
important thing is that if you let
someone write a single module then they
have a sense of responsibility and
liability if something goes wrong it's
their module they know what happened and
they feel responsible for everything
working which is a good thing and but
again that's kind of a guideline of what
things to do and then you go to
application design this is again this is
all very abstract do these do that you
can try to do this you can try to do
that from the scientists point of view I
know that you cannot tell when you're
right but you can know when you're wrong
okay as I mean aerospace engineer I know
that there are other this design
disciplines other than I dial and
waterfall and all the things are
fashionable now doesn't one I
particularly like which is axiomatic
design you probably none of you have
ever heard of axiomatic design don't you
it's a very hidden practice of
mechanical engineering axiomatic design
which worked
that's why Japanese are very good at
engineering it's a Japanese thing it
says is that you can more or less judge
your designs no matter what you're
designing by two axioms you have the
minimum information maximum independence
axiom and minimum information axiom
means that if you have series of
functional requirements whatever they
are a component you're good design is
not bad if those components are very
independent from each other this is the
independent axiom and the information
axiom is that they must use you should
need the lowest amount of information to
describe those components this is the
minute this is the minimum information
axiom if you think about that
they're mutually exclusive it means that
if you try to be very precise okay you
find with you need a lot of information
to define your system and if you want to
be very great brief then your ambiguous
so that's hard there's no maximum
that's no obvious maximum on that okay
so now we're kind of set or ground where
you can start more or less developing
what we know okay we know we have a
criterion to know if we're going wrong
if you're doing things wrong and we know
that we have those big applications
built with components scattered all
around and we have to glue them somehow
okay now we have a huge problem of
complexity a big one because
everything's scattered around and we
have a group of people working
separately so how we deal with
complexity and the thing is that this is
kind of trivial we only have one way of
dealing with complexity that we know and
it works which is abstraction there's
only one I think maybe there's a
philosopher that says with a different
one but I only know about one which is
abstraction if you think about computing
computing is built with abstractions
over abstractions Python is a huge
obstruction you have pandas that is
built on top and numpy that's between
total Python that's an interpreter
interpreted coded in C that has a brutal
machine that translates to bytecode
until ones and zeroes in one piece of
silicon
it's abstraction over abstraction so new
applications are yet another abstraction
so we have components in glue so we have
to design better abstractions to
understand that okay and again remember
that we have this whole thing of the
exotic design that is a kind of
guideline so if we build if we build
very good abstractions that are
orthogonal or independent they're good
abstractions
okay that's independence axiom if we
don't need so much information to define
them then they're good abstractions
because of the information so again good
abstractions are the ones that they've
built a set that is independent from the
one from each other and at the same time
one single abstraction has a lot of
meaning and I will try to exemplify that
so how to make good abstractions
or how to make smart abstractions there
aren't I think that is only one way of
doing that which is talking to smart
people this how we become smarter
talking to smarter people and when I say
that the first time I said that someone
asked me okay
how do you do if you don't know any very
smart people I said I would say okay a
friend will do just pick a friend or a
co-worker and then what happens after
that they say okay what happened say I
don't have any friends and there's a
solution for that too one of the most
important and fruitful experiences we
have is discussing obstructions setting
up a meeting going to a whiteboard and
discussing an abstraction there's one
particular thing about this kind of
building obstructions and organizing
what you're doing it is that
abstractions never get bike-share it
because they're hard in two years I've
never had an unfruitful conversation
about abstractions and let me put some
examples on that oh by the way the thing
in which for which I think that groups
don't discuss abstraction so much is
because they're hard and people get them
wrong all the time so it's very possible
that you get a meeting on your
abstractions and once you've designed
and you get burnt someone tells you
that's not good enough so that's the
kind of attitude that blocks that not
discussing I mean the fear of getting
wrong or being someone tells you that
you're the thing that you have done is
not good enough my advice for that is
that if you're wrong you will have to
correct it anyways so the sooner or
better I have an example for that the
parent project again the glue which is
film is just a part of the pound project
as a functional part which is evaluating
things that have to do with a risk of a
bank for instance mortgages I don't know
if you know but there are like a hundred
kind of different hundred different
kinds of mortgages Bullitt French German
with prepayment without payment
some us are stratified you have problems
of scheduling so you can imagine that
that's a
complexity to how you model all those
marketers and one of them our most
senior developers did that we set up a
meeting and our conclusion was that it
was not good enough and we threw that
away we went with then we tried again
and then one engineer picked the
development said oh every time that I
have to change the code of the mortgage
I have to change three different places
to different files that is not good
enough
and what that engineer did was exactly
what an engineer should do she didn't
know what to do so she immediately set
up a meeting and again what with what
she learned already she discussed the
obstructions with everyone and now we
have a module that kind of works or at
least for some time until we find that
those obstructions are not good enough
and this is the only way so um again
what happens if you don't have any
friends which is kind of a hard thing
then there's only one way which is
writing good documentation it's not that
hard you only have to explain things to
yourself
duck duck stirrings are not good enough
that's the big phrase if you only do
dock strings he's doing documentation
wrong and I think that's one of the
mistakes of how the Java development was
done in my company so you have to
explain things to yourself and that's
something that happened to me when I was
building this glue this thing called
film I we had a first version that had
some hypotheses and it was nice from the
engineering point of view was nice I
mean you had components that were very
similar so scheduler for similar than
workers and the kind of cells or
self-organized
and there was a filter lens built in
them but what happened was that it was
so hard to use then one engineer picked
up and I saw that it was struggling
there was something that it wasn't
working in the abstractions I mean how
you actually had to use the library and
that's bad but how I and then we also
have problems with the jail sometimes
the components freeze but that was that
fixable how I really realize that I had
to throw away three months worth of coat
is that when I started reading
documentation I realized that all that
was [ __ ] so I took what I learned I
throw away three months of work and
started over and it was the only way
okay
I'm not missing anything oh yeah this
this disaster are collateral thing if
you cannot discuss things with anyone
just put it in your coat don't do it
it's over engineering it's the first
step to over engineering no one asked
you for that you're putting anyways
probably will be wrong so don't do it
this is what I happened with the whole
filter and thing I put in the first
library it happened that my company
didn't need fail tolerance because
99.999% offers our user input so why
putting that it's just rubbish from
something that makes the maintenance
more more complex so I also removed that
the second version didn't have any kind
of filter ins because no one needed it
that's it
so again with with this practice writing
good documentation having those meetings
discussing obstructions you get better
and better
again you get you make better
obstructions just how you get smarter
just communicating and practicing and
there's a symptom in which you just you
brief get and this is kind of it's very
difficult to explain you just get it
that you're getting better and better
odds other obstructions it is that when
they just emerged naturally what
happened is that when I was developing
the second version of the glue the pill
thing the film library what I realized
what I was developing is that the wallet
was developing everything was getting
very complicated and I realized that I
needed two levels of abstraction one
level of abstraction that was kind of
the grounded always doing abstraction
such as Reuters can
actions message queues our component
service something that I needed myself
to develop that that was something quite
complicated but of course that ate that
API that obstruction was not good enough
for a user because that's too
complicated that's low level so I built
a second abstraction layer on top of
that that's the one that a normal person
should use so this kind of things that
all I built a two-level abstraction
layer it's kind of okay I'm getting
decent at that not good because of
course I had to change things lots of
things but it's kind of okay I'm getting
into this another important thing about
abstractions you have everything that's
distributed so don't get too much
centered and components those components
have to communicate somehow I need to
design how those components communicate
so that is also a great chance of
designing good obstructions because you
have one guy talking to another guy
maybe one of no successful ideas we had
during those two years is one thing
called ID n ID n is a language in which
the front-end communicates to the
backend ibn is one thing that we use to
describe complete portfolios of
financial institutions and it is a
language that's very easy to parse it
also comes with a small interpreter and
a small virtual machine but it's a
language so that's kind of use him at
obstruction a language and what it
happened to me and I was it's something
that surprised me is that that was not
that hard languages and this kind of
obstructed doesn't seem crazy they're
not that hard to do so I encourage that
if you have two things that have a hard
time communicating with trivial types
like int or strings or whatever you try
to design an obstruction that makes
sense
now we have two components in which the
one component says to another component
this is a portfolio which is nice
so again this is more or less what we
have do we get better or designer
designing obstructions but the problem
is that those obstructions are not most
of them are nor future-proof because
again it's about communicated what
happens with when people leave or switch
department or it's not they had a
hundred percent dedication on that
project they move them to a different
project what happens then and there are
different ways in which we have to deal
with those things the first one is again
writing good documentation but what is
good documentation what really builds a
team when you're building something when
you have someone very close or by your
desk you you don't only tell them tell
him or tell her how that thing works or
how you must call a function usually
tell tell him or her I did that because
I wanted that that was my intention this
is what I pursue so you want some
empathy like that's not arbitrary
I had this has a reason so writing good
documentation and I think that that
pythoness is better than that the
commendation must read like a book
that's important that's what I said one
of the big things here's dog strings are
not enough it should read like a book
and this book should not only have how
to use it it should have also what you
want the reason why you did things that
way because that gives extra information
for the person that's reading what you
did say okay now I get it
this is why this is wrong because that
was his or her intention okay so good
documentation the other important thing
is that I said that we wanted to make
our own library around glue and that
turned out to be successful because we
kind of handled the early risks if you
bind by tool if you build something
yourself you have the risk of not being
successful and having to throw
everything away but that's a low
short-term risk you may be successful or
not the problem is that when when you
use a third-party tool you have a
long-term risk maybe that was not the
right choice maybe you find the buck
maybe you need a hack and you know how
to do it and what happened is that when
we really realized that the film thing
was successful for us is when we started
wanting to hack it
to get more features it was our code it
was our library so we could do it we
knew 100% of lines of code of that so we
could do it and that's great
it means that if we need a hack we can
even turn it into a feature which is
good so again documentation not being
afraid of doing things yourself and
again as I said you need a bookkeeper
you need someone that more or less knows
or everything is because distributive
things get very very complicated gets
scattered all around okay but if you
really want to get a conclusion from
this talk and I think that that
conclusion is important if you start
managing or working with a lot of people
it's getting buried communicating again
it's the only trick okay it's always
said that the good meetings or the good
conclusions are other ones you get after
10 minutes in a whiteboard and I'm
really trying to tell you that you must
go beyond that I mean you can you should
do it without the whiteboard
[Applause]
I'm sharing the gwee flashback but that
was kind of the point
hello I have a question regarding
documentation because at least one of
the problems we have in in our code in
all the works I've done is that is very
easy to like write a first version of
the documentation of what you want to
achieve but what is really hard is to
keep this updated when you when things
change and you have a very complex
environment we move tool with multiple
components is even harder so how do you
how do you manage who used to managing
your work how to other not keep this
documentation updated in a way it's easy
to do and you don't have to concentrate
for every change you do check the
documentation to see if you are breaking
the vision or whatever one of the things
that that it was one of the management's
idea is that we have our recommendation
in our continuous integration system and
and there's some engineers that don't
read the recommendation from the package
but from the continuous integration
system and if they find that something
is not well documented they complain
immediately so the I I've realized that
the the thing that motivates you to
change the commendation of someone
complaining so we kind of encourage that
thing like no here's the documentation
don't ask me with the documentation
there's something wrong complain then we
have a motivation to understand that
documentation is important also for
communication
um you made an interesting comment about
the the Conway's law and the team of
five people and having different modules
and ownership of those modules by
different people I sometimes encounter
that it's when people think of code as
their code that as opposed to someone
else's and that relationship can
sometimes make it so people don't help
out on other people's code because it's
not theirs is this oh I'm not going to
touch that code it's that person's code
do you have any techniques to try to
encourage people to if they find a
problem in someone else's code to at
least you know help with that or to
encourage not siloing people often in
that regard this happening by the way
this happened by mere luck which is that
we found that the model improved so much
when the original developer moves to a
different project so that module was not
his anymore so one picked the
development up and it works so well so
something that I I'd say that maybe is a
nice practice that don't let anyone go
the single module for more than one year
move it to a different thing and pick
another guy that just reviews that sits
down with the original developer for two
one week sometimes you need less than
that explains that module and then picks
up the development so the the sense of
of ownership is also temporary thing I
don't agree that any one must use
develop any code for more than two years
that's not healthy
hello thanks for a talk
regarding to say this this topic in that
particular case don't you fear the
lesson of the new developer to recode
the the company it's happened to me
that's why I Leslie um what happens is
that usually you have kind of a of a
godfather someone that in this case kind
of me someone that sits with down with
the to developers and said ok don't hash
everything don't destroy everything try
to be constructive because that thing
was called by a human being so you must
be polite it's curious because that's a
I think that that's the I mean basically
you you act as a maintainer the same
kind of someone's in a open-source
project wants a new feature usually the
maintainer says look at all the code
probably something that you can reuse
don't just add lines of code because you
want to do it so someone has to act as a
kind of maintainer span and we know a
referee which in between those two
engineers and what it naturally happens
is that and this is important usually
the obstructions change they get better
and your use code that what happened for
instance with a mortgage thing most of
the logic was recycled but the
abstractions change completely so we had
the same functionality with better of
straw abstractions that's the kind of
thing you should encourage with with
that oh by the way there's something I
missed
that's a problem of not having slide
having slides if you realize most open
successful open source projects kind of
use this um and you realize that when
you when you submit a pull request
usually the discussion it's not only
about code but about the intentions
about the abstractions that discussion
also gets that and about the
communication it's good I mean the good
communities have also codes of conduct
to encourage that the fact that that
communication is also fruit
I think that's it with songs anger
medium again
[Applause]